ARTHUR BROOKS: Everybody wants to
know the one secret to happiness.
And there sort of is,
and there sort of isn't.
There isn't insofar as, look, it's a
whole body of literature and science.
There's a whole panoply
of secrets to happiness.
But it all funnels down, at
the very beginning at least,
to one big idea, which is studying
happiness, learning about happiness.
You got to work for it.
The secret to happiness
is working for happiness.
I meet people all the time who
say, I wish I were happier.
Wishing doesn't cut it.
Wishing is no good.
You got to work.
That's why you're taking this class,
to do the work, and it will pay off.
[MUSIC PLAYING]